i know you're a producer on the show i'm
relying on you to spill some tea here
she's got this like love triangle
situation going on then you make a
really tough
argument for emily and ever since i
moved to paris my life has just been
chaotic and dramatic and complicated
what are the pros and cons for alfie and
for for gabrielle i'm team gabrielle 100
you're team gabrielle yeah but my boy
look at that guy he's in his eyes his
eyes light up the room he's a flatterer
you saw that he's a sexy beast it's just
all about charming people what is that
bromance like what is it like working
with him and do you return the favor are
you team alfie i'm a hundred percent
team alfie that was that was honestly
the joke because for me uh emily and
alfie make perfect sense and that's been
the question you know through social
media like are you team alpha and team
gabriel and i was actually
voting for him on the chats and
everything like secretly i love what he
brought to the show because he's really
the antagonist of of what the show is
it's a love letter to paris and he comes
and he's like the sidewalks are filled
with you know stuff and
and like people smell and like and he's
really like
true about what paris can
can be and also so much fun to be honest
with you i'd love love to see emily be
happy she deserves it why do you think
each guy makes sense for her i don't
know she's a romantic but she also loves
to work and she takes her life very
seriously but likes to have fun both
guys give her both of those things they
both bring different sparks to her
personality and they bring out different
sides of her honestly i i don't know who
she's gonna pick that's why i keep
begging darren to give me a clue well
right now gabrielle's a little bit taken
he's in a you know he's with comey she
discovers at the end of the second
season so gabrielle's a little bit off
the table it seems complicated this
relationship between gabriel and camille
so i don't know what will happen i guess
i want my men back but at the same time
it's complicated
and i want my friend back too alfie's
going to london
but you know emily she's got her heart
in work you know i think i'm team emily
i want her to do what's going to make
her happy
i don't think i can make that decision
for her do what's going to make you
happy figure that out and then do what
you have to do so i'm on team emily do
you think she will make a decision and
commit to somebody because i'd love to
see emily in like a committed
relationship in season three yeah i'd
love to see her make a choice
i do feel though however with all of the
ins and outs of the drama
even a choice would be really hard for
her
seems like an easy decision then why
can't i just make it
okay i used to be so decisive i used to
want the things that i should want
season three and season four
congratulations do you think that that
will wrap up emily's journey or do you
think there's a lot more story to tell i
think we'll see at how we do a season
four but right now there aren't plans to
wrap up after season four oh i would
totally go the distance yeah if if they
would have us and people want to keep
seeing more emily and and all the
characters in paris or wherever we end
up i i'm in it for the long haul i
remember me and lily calling each other
when we found out about the two seasons
and i was like wait so we're going to do
as many seasons as we've already done
and lily was like i think that's how
math works but like we're so i'm just so
thrilled to go back i kind of feel like
ferris is a second home to me now and so
just getting to go back there is such a
blessing and i feel like we'll see where
where it takes us i think what darren
does creates these incredible characters
that just keep on giving
and there's drama there's this is
everything that comes with the
characters it builds and
yeah i could live a lifetime watching
the show i'm a fan of the show i'm a big
fan of the show
[Music]